wir auch der monster sehr gefragt ob er
wirklich so authentisch und herzlich sei
die auf den videos es kommt auch
persönlich auf
wir haben morgen wieder kurs ist der
zweite backkurs letztes jahr die schon
ein da hatten wir ein kaufland auf gut
deutsch den arsch tritt gegeben werden
hier sind wir müssten bacchus und ich
will ja ich habe bock aber ich traue ich
mir das nicht zu die organisation und
das ist es dann schon dass wir das jetzt
gemacht haben letztes jahr megacool habe
aber auch etwas daraus gelernt nicht
dass inhalt nicht noch mal gestaltet und
morgen findet derzeit statt
also wir schauen dann im anschluss zu
markus da findet der kurs statt markus
könnte glaubt alle von varianten ein
guter freund inzwischen und fünf minuten
von unserem zuhause entfernt das ist
richtiges heimspiel für uns
[Musik]
und hier
und sich ausruhen und dann hier
passen dann weiter so weit
dass wir das selbst ist ja das ist doch
schon mal als wenig schlüssig
und würde ich mir halt dann auch sehen
etwas mehr gespielt das beste
[Musik]
das ist jetzt keinen platz haben die
ganzen leute zu verstreichen und das
dreht sich in fast jeder bock hat eine
dritte tier wirke aber glaube ich zu der
feier das passt weil das hier noch ein
teilnehmer aber ich glaube man kommt
sich somit den
[Musik]
wir müssen immer mehr hunde blieben
zwölf können wir alle anderen orten
einmal der inhalt hier und fühlen uns
mit ihnen in
ein küchenstudio schließen nur vermieten
für die welt will das anzahl
ja klar
[Musik]
und dann gucke ich meinen großen
wenn das nicht so wie jetzt ist 5
diese machen wir auch
[Musik]
wir beschützen würde ich auch einfach so
da kann man sich ja direkt am anfang an
ziehen ja das recht eigentlich für diese
drei fahrer gestartet haben aber ich
eigentlich fahrt mit der alle
eingeschaltet ist oder man theoretisch
[Musik]
wäre kommen
16 liebevoll
antreten zu sagen ein bisschen weniger
als letztes jahr aber doch immer noch
ich habe das gefühl ich habe den
zeitplan ist besser als letztes jahr
jetzt ist er heute sich nachdrücklich ab
[Musik]
nein
und diese so wenn man sich einmal sind
da ganz viele fingerabdrücke drauf
für die kirche genau das wollen wir ja
auch umstellen aber ich finde glaube ich
dass sie schon stylisch aus wir sind
raus
wir wollen uns ist aufgefallen sind wir
super drauf sind das macht uns ja auch
beim videodreh fahren und ich will
und deswegen wollen wir die jetzt auch
bald so
mattiert angegeben aber das sind ja
super also edelstahl genau
jetzt gibt erstmal diese brocken
transportboxen damit auf die fertige
torte steht damit gelang werden kann die
teilnehmer kommen diesmal von überall
aus bayern ist eine dabei also
eigentlich aus ganz deutschland
freundlich muss fahren jetzt wo ich hier
so ist das erste mal so richtig ist
schon echt anstrengend und man glaubt
gar nicht wie viel dazu gehört so einem
backkurs für 20 teilnehmer zu
organisieren die organisation hat ja
eigentlich schon monate im voraus
angefangen das erste macht viele
gedanken was für ein rezept mache ich
dann brauchst du ein rezept würde zum
beispiel eine küchenmaschine braucht man
hat ja nicht 20 beherrschen muss es
praktisch seine waffen übermacht kühlen
müssen oder so das muss schon alles
bedacht sein ich hätte eigentlich 42
böden backen müssen nur einem ofen ich
habe mein rufen und da passen dann
vielleicht wenn die kleinen sind so drei
reihen und deswegen die heike meister
konditorin hier habe ich hier
kennengelernt durch die planungen für
unserer coffee to go kommt und da bist
du machst ja auch selbst gebackene
bohnen kannst du mir die sich und was
kommt ich mach dir dass ich mach dir
auch die buttercreme fertig und dann ist
schon mal die der dasding gefahren plant
echt zu seit monaten und jetzt in den
letzten tagen intensiver und beauftragt
1000 leute so man so oder so ich jemand
kauft man so eine lange liste einkaufen
im lager die grenzen von der kiku mache
ich die ganze zeit verrückt hast noch
ein und das nur um das tool für die kurs
ja das ist schon echt echten hackmack
aber ich freue mich drauf der stress
wird sich lohnen wir haben parallel noch
den europa
es dort kaffee werden parallel geplant
ist bekommst du ja auch manchmal zu
spüren wenn du bist deinen kommentar
1000 anrufe dann läuft ja auch nicht
alles klappte und dann wirft einen das
verfahren und dann ist man wieder voll
weg von von der organisation hier vom
kurs und denkt nicht dass man jetzt erst
ist die erste box hat mit jetzt noch
weitere 19
[Musik]
wir kommen neuen plattform
wie unangenehm es war 20 teams zu kaufen
die sachen auch ein verkaufter fläche
zwischen der k 20 tüten verkaufen
könnten sie eigentlich auf 922 dazu
kommen eine mehr
unbedingt eine habilitation am 10
deshalb steht der so lecker sind sie
zehn aber so einfach nicht
warum man nicht sehr guten weg ist
fertig eigentlich ist das prinzip
eine roche die opfer werden tipps von
allen choreo die benutze ich auch mal
ganz gerne schulen besuchten über schöne
bescherung hier wollen wir das sollte so
buck bezogen seien aber zum dekorieren
man hier auch benutzen deswegen
kaufen
[Musik]
1000 ja ich freue mich darüber dass ihr
alle da seid und alle gekommen
also haben wir wirklich vorgänger mit
euch heute jeder von euch macht also
schichtet und dekoriert seinen eigenen
tod auch die männern geben soll es
bedeuten würden ich dachte - und ganz
ohne kristall torte bieten wir ihnen an
der st dieser tag ist quasi support
durch unseren partner kaufen und an der
erstmals einen schönen konter
ich hoffe dass wir einen schönen tag
haben und ja ich glaube es jetzt ganz
trocken
[Musik]
spannend auch
aber jetzt alles erstmal reinkommen dann
läuft so ganz gut
[Musik]
für zweierteams immer eine große
schüssel voll vanille buttercreme und
ihr habt vor euch auch marmelade oder
bären ihr könnt gerne wenn ihr möchtet
die torte nicht nur mitunter kim fühlen
also wir fühlen uns streichen mit der
buttercreme und schön findet man ihn
inzwischen schichten einfach noch mal so
ein bisschen frucht ist das natürlich
euch überlassen und da gebe ich euch den
tipp nicht ganz bis nach außen zu
verstreichen denn wenn die buttercreme
obendrauf kommen
bizkit boden dann habe die marmelade und
dann buttercreme ist und dann kann es
sein wenn ich zu sehr nach aus
unterstreicht dass es noch aus sie
quillt daher lieber schön zentral
bleiben und cm einfach frei lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte
[Musik]
und die tore
sollte
ich noch gar nichts
ja wer seine videos gucken
100 tolle produkte vom kauf war
natürlich mehr
[Musik]
zum zum einstreichen weil ich sehe die
meisten sind schon dabei die torte
rundherum einzustreichen ich würde noch
mal ein zwei sätze dazu sagen für alle
diese was weiß ich noch nicht gemacht
haben so benehmen merkt ok wird langsam
ziel und die buttercreme die reaktion so
an den seiten raus dann nehmt ihr euch
die paläste und gehen einfach so am rand
entlang und verstreichen hier nochmal am
rand endeffekt habe natürlich viel mehr
butter kleben es zeichnet das jetzt noch
mal schnell im kopf seht ihr dann quasi
das im drehenden bewegungen ab verlass
uns gerne erstmal bis hierhin alle auf
dem gleichen stand sein und dann zeige
ich euch das noch nicht darüber sprechen
[Musik]
aber das spülen
spielmacher abgegeben die ich über
gute hahn
natürlich jetzt viel mehr bei mir und
das ganze
dann aber entgegen setzen
ja ich würde euch nicht dass hier noch
nicht gespart
das argument vielleicht liegt es ja auch
optisch schön aus wenn man also ein
bisschen noch offen das problem am rand
streiten dann
wird das diese so gehen aber ich schlimm
wie kannst du einfach machen
also ich lasse meine eltern sind dann
nehmt euch wieder gewinne ballett und
wie so ein flug folgerichtig gerade von
der seite dann einfach so rein flugzeug
christian klink aus unserem flugzeug was
du so landet obwohl spricht landesteilen
liess er
[Musik]
außerdem durften ja ja das kenne ich ja
vom ihr mann ist selbst mal zu kritik
schon bei anderen befindet war dann
alles wieder schön
[Musik]
teilnehmer sind unter anlagen auch total
kommunikativen jeder versteht irgendwann
diese wochen kennen das feuer ist
richtig und ansonsten messgerät ort
eingestrichen zu haben eine kühl zeit
ganz entspannt zu haben
für essen und
die backmischung
meine waffen kommen zum einsatz die
macht der täter selber und dann geht es
weiter mit dem
standort
bestimmt aufgeregt haben
hot chips
oh mein gott das ist sehr freuen
wir uns nochmal preisen insgesamt hier
und da immer was auch geschlafen dann
habe ich einfach so eine collage und
dann essen er hatte das wir
hatten
ihr habt ihr für euch jetzt ein paar
zutaten unter anderem raum zucker reis
und zucker mehl in medias haben wir für
euch schon eine gute probezeit von drei
metern hebt ja immer den süßen geschmack
ist ja immer gerne und was wir machen
dass freunde
für euch als mitbringsel für zuhause
oder auch sie verschenken eine
backmischung aus dem klar wenn wir alles
befüllt wird der rechte flaschen mit dem
toppings passiert dass du da bist könnt
euch aussuchen bringt euch gelaufen
tisch
[Musik]
vielleicht nicht so gerne
nochmal
die 13
einfach buttercreme liegt ja auch noch
vor ort inzwischen streiten wir noch das
ist nur noch unser gebe streit kann
quasi das loch was hier
geschaffen haben streicht er einfach nur
noch so ein bisschen zu damit das als
kleber dient so und dann nehmen wir
quasi einfach den erkanntes zockerei so
bis es komplett voll ist und dann können
wir mit dem pinsel dass es das sind
diese blau seiner freundin später noch
auf die linien verstreichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
freudig aufgenommen ganze leidenschaft
[Musik]
so also von mir noch mal ein ganz ganz
großes dankeschön dass alle das war ein
richtig toller tag vernünftig spaß
machen drauf und hat noch mal an details
zum mitnehmen natürlich haben nicht
vergessen der haben überholt klappt und
aus der ecke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und
so einfach herzlich sei wie auf dem
videos kommt auch persönlich
alles gute für dich hab meinem café
besuchen können
zu ende ja es war wirklich ein richtig
schöner tag vor allem ich glaube ich
habe drei vier mann gesagt aber
die chemie hat gestimmt alle waren
einfach so sympathisch alle waren am
ende oft dafür bleiben
somit gehäuse und unaufgeräumt
aufgeräumt sogar nach hause war
also es war wichtig mit verbundenheit
irgendwie so
einfach ich muss erstmal sacken lassen
ich bin richtig glücklich gerade habe
ich
glaube nicht alles mitbekommen aber wenn
es den zusammenschluss online bilder
also hinterlassen ihr feedback wir haben
euch hält sie mitgenommen wie war denn
neuer eindruck hättet ihr auch -
und dann sein
[Musik]